welcome to this video playing attention
master dolly no name ok let's see what
do we get so Kings Indian or green felt
the Kings Indian probably know so I'm
going to try the classical variation and
see what is coming up with Oh Bishop g4
yeah here I actually don't want to
cancel at least not right away yeah
that's an interesting way to play black
it's aiming form for c-54 kind of Bengal
style play I think I'm not not totally
sure that what castling cannot really be
a mistake i believe maybe it can TX
takes b5 it looks a bit strange yeah
that is probably not so bad okay but I
don't I don't need to take absolutely
not i can just can just keep keep things
under control okay yeah the night
doesn't really have great square as am
and maybe here to get it traded some
sometime yeah he actually does that
appeared live okay so i do want to play
a 45 those kind of things um yo do I
want to do something on the queenside or
not
yeah like a three I can say I can also
try to play a three or a four in
appropriate mounam moment moment yeah i
was thinking bishop d 1 i'm not sure if
it is a good idea but if or i can
probably just take yeah Bishop t4 I mean
I'm not taking it give he give him the
c5 square definitely not doing what what
is this kind of movie one he is opening
up his walking side really let's see
that set that looks that looks kind of
curious ok well i just am liking the
bishop see to move here if this would be
also on then this attack would be very
very dangerous already this way i don't
know but it um it will be not easy for
him to play yeah so Queen g3 maybe that
looks good right putting pressure on g6
covering E 1 so look at five look at
five is just a rook no no rookie one
made and that I just need this move to
increase the pressure quite quite
immensely for the capture on g6 or
Bishop b4 35 is also on Queen g5 maybe
for f6 but he's got queen d 8 ok so i
can I could play f6 immediately I can
take first
45
yeah it's not i don't see a win here and
queen the eight remarkable i don't i
don't see any any kind of wind i can
take and try for rookie five but i don't
see you don't see it don't see you in
queen d 8 so it's still kind of solid
how do i how do i improve that maybe I
should have played rook f4 actually I
don't think that should hold j queen age
for 25 though smooth it still has quindi
adium
okay wish the night only five is an
immensely strong defender
time morning yeah what a shame and I
really played this very very badly this
is what's definitely a very good attack
but I completely misplayed it somehow
kind of I don't know h4 might be a move
might be a mistake very very difficult
against the potentially strong night I
mean or potentially it is a strong I
don't know about that
this was really good yeah maybe he has
some breakthrough ideas on the queenside
it might be possible plus he has the
night which is not a great it's not so
great actually now in this position but
it is notoriously tricky check check
check
yeah I'm just marching now the points
are rather quick especially if a knight
is supposed to stop them to it failed
simply that was a very weird way to play
it check check we should be six inches
seven is going to going to kill aboard
requested what no black eyes I enjoy
boating yeah I Boateng is no aboard
there maybe eat the wrong button or
something I know yet it was not a game
that I should have won obviously but um
yeah maybe around here should have but I
really don't know maybe it's not that
bad he's got he's got a good defending
piece there on on e5 but still it fit
fields feels very problematic what is
the comp giving interesting age for him
h4 queen d 8 now look f2 but it doesn't
give me a forced win 0.7 something like
that 0.8 probably you thought here that
should get something but they're
obviously isn't their leg is quick
enough with Queen da druke f8 and his
holding holding age 4 is still good but
here I'm yeah I'm out of out of great
ideas computer says equal it was
probably fair i mean i think probly here
he was too optimistic now which is a bit
understandable he was some under
under lots of pressure or lots of
pressure under some at least yeah he was
definitely worth in some way and now
this is over and heaves looking at the
future with confidence but maybe this is
not really a position that you can I can
easily play for a win chat yeah and so
here this is already already critical
right yeah it is computer is on 0.6 so
it it acknowledges the problems the
problem is that when f ng porn had
traded i have the fre h pawn and it's
always difficult for a night to play
against the flank porn the porn might be
enough to distract the black pieces so
that ultimately can someone enter and
pick up horns which was all the more
evident here after he did not take after
this after this it's lost right yeah hyy
twins yeah I'm just I'm just jab pushing
the pawns whom yes act he has no way to
stop them Jack straddles funny how quick
this this was was all of a sudden um
going downhill yeah he has to be content
probably with them with an equal
position somehow maybe just stay and
I'll like a for this is always useful
maybe a three to get those some
sacrificial ideas in computer says equal
I mean I don't know maybe black is a bit
more comfortable but it's some it's not
so easy
engine wants to do this move and after
that basically wants to shuffle with
about equal play yeah maybe he
definitely wanted a bit too much which
is understandable as i said but maybe
the position is not that really offering
more and he is its kind of kind of
tricky okay this is a mistake but it's
interesting and what happens here a form
is there do i really have winning
chances in this position it's an
interesting question a force is is also
i can maybe take that hmm but probably I
would have played the check this is the
most likely scenario king here maybe
King F for a three page five well that's
probably a draw right you can always ok
I can get the Bishop to g4 maybe if this
is not too risky like here here can i
play that or is the g5 the move t5 is
coming right and I am does this kind of
thing so it's very very critical so
maybe you have to go there ha sham
probably draw it I don't see a way
forward compass on 0.5 which probably
means a draw the either is something
direct happening that I can enter or not
and if not then this is just like a
symbolic advantage with the edge porn
but nothing really going on ok thanks
for watching